you know what i'm feeling i'm feeling
confident i'm feeling confident because
i'm here with nanny bobby in the kitchen
i love that i love kendall in the
kitchen i love being with nanny bubby in
the kitchen and this is all thanks to
chapman automotive sponsors this segment
and you have
brussels sprouts today is that fun you
know what's funny about this what is i'm
such a novice to cooking i never knew
that this is how they looked on
i i never did either until last
christmas season okay so i don't i don't
feel crazy
these go off the shelf
after christmas and you will not find
them again until thanksgiving and i
didn't know that but this is is this
gorgeous you can't find fresh brussels
sprouts you cannot find them on the
stove oh on the stock okay yeah isn't
that can you that's really is that
amazing i've never seen that before all
right so let me tell you how to prep
them they're so great so you wanna i've
i've washed them but in real time look
how easy this is you're to cut that off
and take off some of these leaves jump
in there and just cut off some of these
extra leaves just one or two oh okay
they're kind of tight so
just a clip here and a clip there okay
in real time look how easy this is ready
yep we're going to spray
what are you spraying avocado oil thank
you instead of olive oil because the
olive oil doesn't do well on high heat
avocado oil it becomes toxic or canned
so you're better off with an avocado oh
good you said that because i use olive
oil for everything not in the oven okay
not over 325 degrees that's good okay
salt okay okay both sides turn it for me
got it
there we go
all turned now some ground pepper i'll
let you grind the pepper let's talk
about the edge of this stock right down
here where we are okay you um this will
stick out over your pan you can do two
things you could cut the stock which i i
mean you need a lumberjack to cut this
stock can i tell you or you just put
them like that
and throw them on there and roast them
with the rest of it what is great about
um
about roasting them on the stock is that
they are raised up and the air from the
oven gets in it and underneath it that's
what makes them crispy and brown all
over and you just roast them regular
they're kind of mushy on the bottom so
now we're going to make a dipping sauce
ready yeah i'm ready mayonnaise okay
dijon mustard did you say mayonnaise i
said mayonnaise is that okay i guess i'm
a texas guy mayonnaise
oh my gosh i just made a huge mess all
over everything which means that we're
doing something right i love that a
little bit of stevia you could use sugar
but i like the liquid okay stevia now
white balsamic vinegar you have white
and dark hair yeah because i wanted to
show you the difference okay it's white
if it's light in color just like this
it's dark if it's that don't use that
use the white balsamic vinegar because
this wouldn't ruin it this wouldn't
taste like it just changes the color
right so a little bit of that squeeze
some lemons in there for me
a little bit of cayenne pepper just for
fun
that's honey bubby measures
the boop sound yes that's the official
should i do two lemons yeah go ahead
okay we're putting it in
okay we're going to take the dipping
sauce right here
and we're going to put it right over
here in this bowl and then what i'm
going to do is show you
this just came out of the oven as you
saw right before we hit the air on the
nanny bubby segment right okay here is
melted butter
imagine this on a charcuterie board on
your table during the holiday you're
going to take some butter and glaze over
the top like this look at that it's
really a great presentation that's the
thing it goes on the table in the middle
of the table everybody you know can
carve out it if you like it you take
more maybe you put two of these one on
one side of the table one on the other
everybody can take a fork and a knife
now we're going to take some french sea
salt and it's bound to be a conversation
piece too because like you and i a lot
of people
don't know that they grow on stalks like
this or this is what it looks like sofa
though oh i've never seen them it's such
a conversation a little bit of french
sea salt sticks to the butter i love
that make sure you raise your hand way
up because you have more control when
you sprinkle at the end i like it plus
it just looks better okay it just looks
more fun so what you're going to do is
serve it like this for a serving part on
each side and a knife right
and you're going to start your forks
start it start it start it go just well
here put your hair like this how about
here okay fork in
knife cuts it
take that all right maybe it's oop is it
too hot or too big is it crispy is it
good oh my gosh how about that that is
so good so good do you love it i love it
okay not just white all right but you
gotta finish this because i have a
mouthful oh you want me to finish it
okay check out nanny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com also we want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring the
segment and jillian no rocky over to you
so good thank you nanny bubby i
definitely want a taste of those so save
me some kindle